[Music]
extremities is back and better than ever
but it's going to be different much has
changed since the last season of the
extremities podcast
travel screeched to a halt and with this
standstill went my ability to visit
document and share the stories of far
away places
yet through all the changes in tumult
brought on by the last 18 months
some things have stayed quite the same
printably
telling stories of the world's most
remote settlements remained a
core interest of mine and so while
serving the same purpose
to access and explain the isolated and
difficult to comprehend corners of the
globe
extremities is returning but in a new
form
and this time you're going to need a
screen extremities is relaunching
as a standalone youtube channel for
those of you curious as to how a civil
war influences one of the most
biodiverse islands on the planet
how french culture perpetuates in the
sub-antarctic and why centuries-old
atlantic island communities have been
all but abandoned over the course of
just a few decades
come on over to the extremities channel
right now and give it a watch
the first two videos are up now the
third will go up in a week
or it's on nebula now and then more will
go out every third wednesday after that
each video features interviews with
locals and experts alike
taking you to the place introducing you
to its people and telling its story
ad free episodes along with extended
cuts of interviews will also be
available for nebula subscribers
so head to this link clickable at the
top of the description to watch and
subscribe to wendover productions's
newest channel